when I was 13 I took the 11 plus to get
him to this is like my biggest life
lesson so it's a bit weird but I'm
nothing to do a sport either but when I
was no not 30 when I was 11 10 you take
the 11 plus to go into schools and I
remember up until that age I've been
quite fortunate where I've been getting
decent results but being in class
chatting to my friends you know I mean
just being Chat Chat Chat Chat like I am
now and not always concentrating and I
remember I didn't get into the school
that I wanted to and then I got in on
like the second wave of results but I
was really upset that I didn't get in
the first time because I fully expected
to I remember my parents kind of sat me
down and they were like to see like we
know you're intelligent and we know
you're talented obviously if you don't
work hard it doesn't mean anything so
you have to work hard to be able to
achieve stuff and when you learn that
like 11 years old or 10 years old it
stays with you so I always think it's
great that I'm like fast it's great that
I'm talented but without hard work every
doesn't mean very much because there's
most people that talented in the world
but you do have to work hard to achieve
your goals so yeah well that's really
going to help you isn't it the build-up
to the Olympics of course because
there'll be so much focus on you
building up to Japan how do you deal
with that
a lot of pressure now I just keep going
like normal from being honest yeah I
think I'm getting a bit more comfortable
with there being more attention I think
if you ask me a few years or even last
year I would have been like oh no no
please just just don't look at me kind
of and I'm still a bit like that don't
get me don't get me wrong but I think
I've kind of interpreted as people want
you to do well and people are hoping
that you do well which is absolutely
lovely
obviously people's hopes and aspirations
are completely distinct from the hard
work that I still need to do and it's
distinct from what actually might happen
on track because you still got to put in
the work to be successful but it's just
well wishes and its really nice that so
many people want me to do well no Russia
team at the Olympics because they've
been bound by water for four years this
week what do you think about that well I
think in track and field I think they
were already banned as a nation so
within the track and field sport there's
no real change for us but obviously like
I want a clean sport so it's really
important that the big international
governing boys are taking that step and
it's a good one when you've raced
against a
girls have you ever been in a situation
where you thought I don't trust their
performances no I've never stood on the
line and thought that simply because
that's not the right mentality to go
into a race with when I stand in the
light and you have to be ready to race
whatever is there
it doesn't matter kind of what the
circumstances are whether it's windy
whether it's cold or whether there's
something else what does the build-up
then look like to Tokyo so between now
and then training clothes are hard work
training I've probably start racing at
about May Junie time which I'm not
completely sure about but definitely
making sure that we're at the mill
anniversary games in the summer which
I'm so excited for because that would be
actually the first opportunity that I'm
able to stand in front of a British
crowd as a world champion which is a
crazy thought but yeah and what what can
you do or not do between now and then
that other things you can't eat yeah
okay so tell us that no cakes and now a
love cake cakes brownies ice cream apple
pies oh no I know all the fun things all
the fun things but ultimately it's all
worth it because if you retire after
having a great career you can eat all
the cake slaughterous you're like in the
middle of Doha it was the verge of
Sallisaw scandal broke in the middle of
it what was the locker room chat about
that
what was it but the athletes kind of
thinking okay good or we had no idea
you're not it no of course not because
we were all focusing and I run in like
we're not really you can't when you're
obviously in a performance environment
like you can't be focusing on stuff
that's happening outside it so I
remember it was press post post champs
they always asked us about like you are
now we're all like what were you talking
about because obviously it's like it's
our defining moment so when it's like
it's our lives like this is what I've
been running for since I was 8 years old
13 years old so when it comes down to it
we're just completely focused on what we
have to do so whatever's happening like
outside that it's particular it doesn't
pertain to us is we weren't aware what
what's your dream when you when you
think through you know forward to July
to the Olympics yeah and do you can you
allow yourself to think about collecting
oh no no we don't think about that
simply because I have to Train so hard
to get there and then I have to race I
have to make the team
and I have to get that injury free so
there are a few quite a few small but
significant hurdles that you have to
overcome before you can even think about
the Olympics and even when you do you
don't start thinking about the result
afterwards when you've got to do the
races first so